so notice back in our diagram that the
object that has the dot local property
each of these car objects in our program
has not been generated from whole cloth
anymore we passed it through a decorator
function and when it came back out it
was given the dot local property
pointing to whatever value it has
decorators can add more than just simple
properties like this number
remember functions are properties to
maybe we'd prefer to call the move
function using method calling syntax
which means we would look it up as a
property of ami before invoking it on me
if we want to do this we're going to
have to refactor our code again so take
a moment to refactor this code in a way
that would enable us to use this method
calling syntax with dot access